Cái chi tiếp ở đây mà chúng tôi hướng đến nó không phải là cô chuyện bán mức cái nhà.
Nó cũng không phải là cô chuyện bán mùi đô thịt, mà là bán cái trải giữa của tinh cả nhân trong một gia đình đấy.
Chúng ta có thể cá những cái cân nhà mà nó giống nhau về hình thất bên ngoài, giống nhau về quy môi dịt, đặc cùng bên cạnh nhau.
Nhìn chúng ta lại cá sử khách nhau về cái cách tổ chức trong không danh,
giống chúc nó là bộ trợ. Hay nói chính xác hơn nó là định hình của quả trình dình thành dịch vụ, và dịch vụ thì có phần gứng ở phần này.
Trong khi đó thì con người là như được gọi là trải tiên một tà mộ thành dịch vụ đó.
Mình chai gặng là lối sống về một người thế giên chi sẽ với môi trường là lối sống đánh cấp, lực sửa rì thầy này.
Chính kết sửa chi tiếp, nó mới nói để mức lộn để tâm, sửa thấu hiệu của những người cũng cấp dịch vụ hay sản phẩm đỉnh.
Đến với hành của mình, vì nếu như không để tâm không thực sự hiệu của người ta muốn cái gì người ta cần cái gì thì sẽ không thể đưa ra không cấp được,
Những kể thiết kế hay là những cái gì bụng mang kính chất và tìm bị đến tình góc lộm mộn.
Khiến tạch trải hiện sướng tầm nó không nằm ở một cái gì nó quá, nó có bố bố lớn,
mà nó đến tình góc lộm mộn như vậy.